لا محفظات الملا بالكتب تقسم ظهر التلميذ
لقد استبدلت السبوره والطباشير بنظارات
الواقعه الافتراضي انها بيئه تعلم ذكيه
تدمج تكنولوجيا المعلومات والاتصالات في
الفصول الدراسيه في مدرسه ريدم هاوسكو
بمقاطعه باكشا بجنوب انجلترا استخدموا
التلاميذ نظارات الواقع الافتراضي لدخول
تجربه انغماسيه لمجموعه متنوعه من الدروس
التفاعليه في بيئات افتراضيه مشابهه تماما
للبيئات في الواقع او ما يسمى
وسواء تعلق الامر بالاقتراب من حيوان
الماموث المنقرض او التلاعب بالكواكب
الشمسيه فان تقنيه الميتافيرس هي الدعم
الذكي لعمليه التعلم
الحفظ رائع بمجرد ان يرى التلاميذ شيئا ما
سوف يتذكرونه وهناك فهم اعمق لانهم
يستطيعون التلاعب بجسم ما اذ يمكنهم رؤيته
من جميع الجوانب ورؤيه كيفيه عمله ووظيفته
عندما يمكنك الانكماش والدخول في قلب
الانسان
لاستكشاف وظائفه الداخليه في واقع افتراضي
نابض بالحياه قد لا يكون فصل علم الاحياء
هو نفسه مره اخرى
علم الاحياء مناسب جدا للميتافيرس لانه
يمكننا استكشاف اشياء مثل الخليه وكيفيه
عملها وحتى النظر الى القلب اذ يمكن ان
نرى كيف ينضج وتدفق الدم من خلاله ويمكننا
فهم التجويفات والصمامات ما يعني حرفيا
التجول داخل القلب واشياء من هذا القبيل
وهذا مفيد جدا للاطفال ويساعدهم في فهم
اعمق لما يدرسونه
مدرسه مشروع اطلقته مجموعه
الدوليه باستخدام مدرسه
العريقه موقعا للواقع الافتراضي وهو مشروع
تجريبي سيكون متاحا من اي مكان في العالم
حيث تعرض الموضوعات بما في ذلك العلوم
والتاريخ والفن والجغرافيا مع الطلاب
الذين يعملون معا في بيئات تشبه الحقيقه
وتضفي على المستخدمين سعاده
وجاذبيه ومتعه في التواصل